thank you
[Music]
I'm gonna tell you guys a really amazing
story of a woman named Teresa Weiler
well she's 64. and
whenever people ask her hey you're 64.
uh do you have grandchildren yet
um do you even have kids it always like
hits her because she never wanted to
have kids for a very specific reason why
because she [__] hates them
it's something that like so when I read
this story I didn't know why she
wouldn't killed her father
a lot of people that don't want to have
kids though getting killed her [__] dude
how about patricide all kids what about
fear of patricide what's that like
you're you're kidding I I legit think
about that yeah I legitimately think
about that sometimes yeah I do because
like what if I have a psycho kid like
sometimes it's like a you know like
being a sociopath or something is like a
mental
um disorder where they don't have they
don't have empathy so they don't really
like I don't know they could become a
killer and they don't really care I
think about that a lot it's really
terrifying actually yeah there's a lot
of thinking about this it's like and I
think about like what if I have to kill
them before they kill me it's like Gary
it's like Gary Sinise and Lenny say
thank you thank you
yeah and it's gonna be harder on you to
do it before they do it to you you but
you know you have to be doing it to be
fair Lenny had empathy he was just like
don't but Gary Sinise could see hi he
could see it he didn't want to do it he
was just so strong he couldn't handle it
yeah
Uncle Ben say he goes with great power
comes great respiration yeah
thank you for the respiratory Lieutenant
Dan Lieutenant Dan would say this at the
one minute 40 seconds
why is this lady choosing to be Barren
okay and useless to society not having
children dude it goes It goes so deep
but um so let's keep it shallow baby her
story basically like she fell in love so
many times in her life and she would
always cut the relationship off because
she could not bear to tell her partner
like hey I'm I can't I not that she
can't she refuses to have kids and for a
reason that like hurts her so let me
tell you her life story she was um when
she was born
um in London it was 1958 she was
abandoned at um at the hospital her
mother who came in with her friend uh
they they go okay uh we're gonna come
back for her later after she was born
and they just never came back oh she
ended up being adopted by an amazing
family
um that's cool okay yeah she had a great
life great parents everything was
awesome sounds like you're dotted a
bullet at some point she wanted to find
her biological parents so she goes and
and uh inputs her name in this like
filing system we're like oh if her
parents want to find her they'll know
that she's looking for them kind of
thing and then 23 of May something like
that yeah but this is like in in I think
the 80s or something
um she's 26 by the time she gets a file
that tells her who her parents even are
um so at 26 she gets this folder she
starts looking through it and she finds
out that her mom was 16 when she had her
and her dad was 14. 14. 14. whoa
I thought you said 40 of first one okay
well 14's a little better yeah so that's
just High School lovers yeah yeah but
then she she sees later in the page he
got older that's Championship they're
brother and sister oh
[__]
see God damn six she got part of the
Royal Family
[Laughter]
true yeah
hell yeah they do that
allegedly UK right cousins they were
cousins yeah yeah Windsors only [__]
Windsors you know what I'm saying gotta
keep it in the family my boy so is she
scared of like uh she's scared of
[__] her brother
so hot dude this fish is carrying like
jeans that are like like not preferred
or whatever yeah yeah
she's scared to make more sense for her
to mix with like outside jeans well you
don't know that's the thing she's
terrified that whatever kid she has is
gonna have a defect and then the
partner's gonna go what the [__] is this
and she's gonna have to say oh sorry a
lot to like over and out
she what she'd rather post about it well
no that's not that at this point of the
story she's what's attention she's kind
of like because the clouds chaser
the crazy thing is she she was able to
get in touch with her mom and dad who
are her you know are they still together
that's a valid question bro they are
actually it's weird oh [__] so so she
she went over like Mom Dad Auntie Uncle
[Laughter]
the room oh [__] she goes she wanted to
get answers she because she didn't know
that if she was born out of like
non-consensual like yeah things or
whatever uh or if it was a secret yeah
that they never told their parents and
then they just like left her there so
she goes and visits and she's she kind
of like loses composure because of the
heightened emotions of it and she kind
of gets like really angry and starts
like asking like what the [__] happened
blah blah and he's like you try having a
hot sister
it's not [__] easy washing machine
Bros always wanted to talk about that
today yeah yeah yeah with everybody in
the room together
you try resisting curves like that she
is really have you seen my sister and
you know what we want to dive into that
deeply maybe on the next level you know
what I'm saying she goes um so the mom
and the you know Dad aka brother they
they did they don't give her any answers
because they're just like hey maybe you
should calm down and what ever or you
should and they end up kick around it's
not that weird yeah exactly that's kind
of how it was yeah they were kind of
like not seeing the whole thing and they
kicked her out for like 20 minutes
denial yeah are they like brothers and
sisters [__] nature all the time yeah
dude oh how did Adam and Eve so she
never got her answer but at the same
time continued [__] after that 40
years later she's finally kind of just
forgiven herself for it because you know
she didn't let it uh kind of dictate who
she was the Lannisters had three kids
yeah they were they're great kids yeah I
mean it was fine it's a it's a dice roll
it's just they became princes and
princesses
one adult but that's you know that was
the sign of the times you know a lot of
kids didn't make it past
20. and they died beautiful yeah the
crazy thing is that she said that if you
took a picture of all three of them
together it would look like a normal
beautiful family but it's like she's
like but it's actually like super [__]
up to think of that you know what though
some you see some couples that look like
brother and sister
what's up with the Grits you know as
soon as I said it I was like that it
feels who are you hinting towards nobody
I'm just saying like you know you see
some couples in the street and you're
like we don't look like brother and
sister but we're trying to have
accepting attitudes around here in the
Attitude Era oh I see yeah yeah that's
true that's true my bad they say you
either pick someone that looks exactly
like you or polar opposite that's true
yeah I can't tell what I picked I can't
say we all kind of picked opposites do
you think you start looking like each
other over time though I hope not I
think dogs and their owners do yeah yeah
oh yeah look at your mannerisms oh yeah
that's true but that's just all it's
always funny when you see a fat short
person with a bulldog yeah the dogs in
there
and it's like a skinny skinny guy with a
skinny skinny Chihuahua yeah
my favorite so she thought messy
Chihuahua messy guy she kept it a secret
basically I know a shivering man
and when she finally told her biological
parents or not her biological her
adoptive parents she thought they were
gonna like she thought her old family
would be girl style because she has like
uh siblings and stuff with this adoptive
family and she told them all and they
were just really supportive she's kind
of likes her siblings she's trying to
like break the ice yeah
doesn't mean we should [__] do you think
unless we think you should have you guys
ever heard of the Whitaker family yeah
yeah the ones in the [__] Appalachian
they said like because I think in most
people's mind when you hear about like
incest or inbreeding like that you think
they're always going to be like [__]
up immediately like heels have eyes yeah
but isn't it like it takes Generations
right it takes like a lot more oh yeah
which is what she's trying to stop
layers of layers royal family those
[__] up teeth like that exactly that's
what I'm saying they're very well the
French had the breathing problems and
stuff what's that the
um the the the French were doing that
too French royalty like the Louise and
stuff like that and then they kept on
doing it Adventure ah Le bronchitis
one of the most precise inbred family
hugs are like that too yeah exactly one
of the most inbred families in Europe is
are the hasparks hasbergs they're one of
the most powerful families in Europe
that married all of them are they
mentally like [__] well one of them
was became I think the prince or king of
Spain and you you he looks like the Mac
Tonight McDonald's
and then uh [__] Spain yeah and then
they say that like he was all like
mentally ill and like [__] see I'd
rather be that though because you don't
know that you're like true same with um
the ancient Egyptians that's why King
Tut was only like 12 or some [__] when
he died or whatever yeah he was part
alien that's true how much of that
though is is like he's born with his
brain all [__] up and how much of that
is a bunch of kids being like hey you
look like the Mac tonight
he grew into the role yeah yeah
wow right that's a damn that's a look
imagine having a [__] that a [__] up
artist yeah yeah so so this is the this
is the hasberg's curse right all of them
have this weird jaw if you look at all
of the family members and that and back
in the day yeah
I'm going to start incorporating the Mac
Tonight McDonald's guy into my
references oh my God
yeah you said it so plainly like he's
[__] narrating a documentary
deep cut bro and their family looks like
they're better tonight McDonald's
the whole family
it's all of the members of their family
they have this weird Gene and it's also
because like you know a lot of
inbreeding happened with the Royals yeah
and that was like one of the richest
powerful families they had it wrong huh
they missed the mark they really did
there's more relations from good
intentions though all the royal families
from like Russia all the way to Spain
they're more related than the than the
people of the countries because they all
married each other so they're all like
cousins and [__] wow yeah dude exactly
that's why they kept doing the family
because they're like we gotta keep alien
blood yeah
foreign